was that when you were locked up was
there was there dudes getting [ __ ] in
the ass in there
yeah yeah i walked in on somebody
getting [ __ ]
that's just great i didn't know about
the coke cans what's the coke can
like somebody taking care of their
business in the pen either jerking off
or [ __ ]
yeah they put the coke can on on the end
of the uh
thing by the shop by the shot so you
walk in and you just
i didn't know about the man on man [ __ ]
popping penitentiary
well it's crazy because you'll see like
somebody who's straight and then they
end up in jail for life and then they're
dabbling in the in the whatever tyson
was saying you know what i'm saying
yeah that [ __ ] is crazy so so would you
like if you're in jail and you let's say
you want to rub one out you gotta put
the coke can up
or is that just you do something do you
do in your bunk uh nah you gotta you
gotta put the cocaine up if you taking
care of [ __ ] in the shower
you know so that put people on game you
know what i'm saying but i didn't know
about that
this was four days me and the pen you
know i wake up early to get my incidents
peel calls so i got to wake up before
here but all the people call people
right they wake up at like four o'clock
so i walk down on a [ __ ] riding
a dick
a grown ass man
yeah that image is probably never
leaving your head you know
like how do you react to that you're
just like i see it my bad
did you see the guy later and be like ah
now i know i know i know about you
like for the next nine years you're like
like or however long you were locked up
with this guy you're like i saw you get
[ __ ] in the ass bro
he's crazy yo it's not but he's a [ __ ]
like [ __ ] don't hide in there like
okay
oh okay okay they know what they're like
they're they're like [ __ ] [ __ ] are
labeled [ __ ] they call about their
name they call by women names
like they don't piss onside you they
have to sit down and piss
in the penitentiary you know if you're a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] is not in a
it's not you're a [ __ ] you if your name
clarence is close it's clarity
or something you know saying you're a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ]